I was at Harvard yesterday looking at
Harvard Business School
and quite a few people there had read
about me or read my blog and they said
why are you considering this school and
I said well my profession is based upon
presentation and perception and I
believe that I have what it takes to
create a successful company right now I
would love to know some underlying
skills I would love to learn those but
more than anything it's a fuck-you
credential and I do want to make
fuck-you money and I I do I say that
because I think there is a general trend
and this is not something that is even
remotely new that I'm bringing up but
people aren't really talking about it
right now young women entrepreneurs do
not exist they don't exist young men
start companies all the time young women
don't why is this I would love to start
addressing that I would love to I would
love for it to be a topic of
conversation it's not even a topic of
conversation why is it that half of us
small businesses are run by women but
none of them practically none of them
are in their 20s they're all they'll
have kids in school why is this I'm
guessing it's biology but I think that
one of the ways to garner respect in
this industry unfortunately one of the
only ways is to basically make a ton of
money my goal is to sell non Society
within three to five years I pushed it
up to five because of the economy but